my guest tonight is an actor producer
and writer who starred in the film super
bad knocked up and the 40 year old
virgin
please welcome our good friend seth
[Applause]
[Music]
rogen
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
to be out very it's really good isn't it
really good to have an audience
it is wonderful it's it's so weird
adjusting just
think people without masks are the smart
people now is what
it's a really weird adjustment for me
uh yeah it's i don't know what to i
didn't know whether to shake your hands
or not just now
i don't know what to do we're in a weird
moment
we're sort of in between and so i always
have a mask on me and i have put it on
but then other people go like what are
you doing i'm gonna take it off and then
someone else might say put it back on no
it's weird yeah
i don't know whose hand to shake and
some people are fist bumping a dude came
up to me
uh on the street and recognized me and i
just found myself motorboating him i
just didn't
i did i just i just i don't know why i'm
doing this
i don't know it does keep the spray to a
minimum yeah
it's a very it's not a contagious area
of your man breasts
are you uh but i mean but it looks like
i mean yes it's a very strange period
but i think we're going to navigate our
way oh yeah but
i'm also filming a show right now and
and what's weird is hollywood
production has generally not adjusted to
the fact that we are all vaccinated we
are all still wearing our masks
all day as we're filming and it mostly
drives me crazy because i hate it when
republicans are right about anything
and i know that right now if a
republican came to our set was like
you're a bunch of like virtue signaling
hollywood i'd be like
you're right we are there's no need for
these masks
you think it's got yeah because they're
still blocking people up into zones red
zone blue zone yellow zone it's so
meaningless yeah we're motorboating each
other out here guys
let's take the masks off you can't get a
good motorboat with a mask on well
i beg to disagree let's try it dude when
i was a surgeon
uh yeah you know i want to thank you
because
you were uh you're my first guest on the
tbs show
uh 11 years ago i was and uh very
very nice to do it it's a long time ago
now it was a long time ago yeah
it is a it's a rare distinction in
comedy to be someone's first guest on
their second
talk show actually it was my third that
was your
talk show yeah even
conan's had 45 shows i know i was like
this is the one 38 years
[Laughter]
it was a real honor honestly and i know
you were literally telling me backstage
how you don't like hearing this but i
grew up watching
your show um when i was i think 12 years
old when
uh it first came on so um you know
things like the masturbating bear
honestly were like the things i grew up
uh
obsessed with comedically and were truly
like some of my favorite things and then
i got older
and i i got uh to be an actor and i got
to be on the show and i remember the
first time being backstage
and meeting the masturbating bear and
i was like honestly star struck like it
was
it was truly like meeting like tom hanks
or something for the first time
who incidentally also was masturbating
i saw him yeah so it was a lot like
meeting tom hanks yeah
no i actually do like i pretend i kind
of don't like it but i'm very happy when
i when
younger comedy people say oh i mean bill
hader
last night was saying he was whatever he
was 15
16. and would watch it with his friends
and really think this is so weird and
their parents would hate it but they
would like it and i thought
oh that was nice we separated children
from their parents
exactly anyway yes not that i needed
that done
anyway it re it reaffirmed the wedge
that was
driven between me and my family yeah um
yeah no my mother loves the masturbating
bear
oh good sign of class um you know i had
a
you know question for you uh which is
you seem like a guy and i've known you
for a long time
um you seem like a guy who's i don't
know relax
centered like you know who you are yeah
uh i'm going to have
a lot of free time now for a while we're
going to start something else up but
i'm going to have some down time and i
honestly i'm not even kidding
i don't really know what to do with down
time yeah i get that sense from you
yeah really tell me yeah i do i mean i
remember doing
your live show in vancouver after and i
remember being with you backstage
we were just like what is happening
right now like why are you doing this
i demand i demanded that that i had all
the time to like take some time off
before we started the next thing i'm
like no
we're doing more shows all across the
country
and i think theaters yeah i needed to be
medicated but it was still a lot of fun
no it was a pleasure to play a part in
your therapy
but uh yeah i think you do have time on
your hands i would suggest
uh this is gonna be hilariously on brand
try smoking a lot of weed for a long
time
i mean try it you seem like someone who
doesn't smoke a lot of weed to me
uh i don't smoke any weed and that's not
a judgment i i am kind of
uh uh lucid i enjoy
my lucidity never a sentence i've even
thought in my life
but it's true like i'm not i am not well
andy you you've known me a long time
i've
i it's not that i have any problem with
people uh smoking pot i think it's
actually
you know a seems to be a fine herb uh
but i enjoy it ever a sign you didn't
smoke weed it's that you just called it
a five
it's a fine herb as i'm told but the
couple of times i've tried it like it
didn't
nothing really happened well yeah and
then i
i think it metabolizes and becomes more
orange pompadour
but you but i know that you own a weed
company so you might actually have
you might be able to tell me maybe i was
smoking the wrong stuff yeah
you know i don't know i don't know what
would you you know me what would you
want me smoking
okay
i swear to god this is how this is how
this is how lame i am for a second i
thought he brought a birthday candle
that is no birthday candy no don't smoke
that now this will be a
or do this will be a great weird show
for all what is this
what is it real what is it really what
is weed i know it's weeds
i didn't think it was pencil shaving but
i'm curious like are you you were
as a professor of weed telling me that
this is the kind you think i should use
i think you should take
one hit of that weed one hit of that
weed
and i think you'll have a really good
time okay yeah
light i don't have a light do you have a
light does anyone have a lighter yeah
this is the kind of thing you do when
you know it's over for you
[Applause]
oh what are they gonna do what are they
gonna do to me
i'm so nervous right now i know
seriously
[Applause]
i really 120 people other ways either
way
i really don't know what to do
all right all right tell me and then you
just get ready okay yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right
i'll hold on to this right you better
hold on to that
when does this thing that's gonna happen
happen uh well we'll wait a few minutes
and see how you feel and then maybe you
have a little bit more if you're uh
still functional
i'm driving a school bus in an hour yeah
good right
now people are going to be looking for
anything i do and be like
exactly like i'll do this and be like
he's hot
and i've been doing that for him for a
long time
i was complimenting you backstage i'm so
happy with what just happened
[Applause]
i i'm actually i wasn't expecting any of
this i'm not because
i forgot i applied for a job at target
i'm laughing way too long
anyway wow yeah is it supposed to burn
it kind of burns
it's very much supposed to burn that's
exactly any smoke inside your body
right because i sucked it in right right
okay
all right i like how controlling i am
about it i'm
you know being like i'm like a narc that
they
to prove that he was not a narc it's
true truck said it's like a
tip some drugs yeah do you ever get wet
conan
that's what denzel asked in training
date yeah yeah
well when you have to explain a joke you
know
he's meaner because he's hot that's what
happens to me i become
don rickles um you wrote this book i was
commenting you backstage you're going to
be okay
i am i'm so happy you wrote this book
yearbook
and and so many that's nice i do
there's so many times i read someone's
book and i have to read it because i
gotta
then interview them and maybe the the
book's okay but it's not
it's not something that i would
necessarily talk about a lot and then
what happens is i
i get past it in the interview and i
don't really touch on it that much
i read your book and then uh you and i
did the podcast
and that's all i could talk about it was
so good
fantastic his book if you have not read
his book
thank you and you have this
so many great stories but you wrote
about working with snoop dogg i did a
fantastic story
thank you yeah um speaking of weed i was
uh i
we made a film called this is the end um
around eight years ago
uh in that film yeah there's a song that
craig robinson uh sings called take your
panties off
which um i would argue has not aged well
but we thought it would be fun uh if at
the end of the movie there was like a
more produced version of the song
that was like a real song and then what
if snoop dogg was on the song was what
we thought and we asked
snoop dogg and he's like i'll be in a
song called take your panties off that
doesn't seem like
a stretch for snoop talk and so
we met in the recording booth him and
craig were there we were all smoking
we'd snoop had a man who rolled joints
for him that was his only job that was
truly i can confirm that because the
times i've been
around snoop i have seen that happen yes
he has a man who does that for him like
that is a human's
job which uh is honestly like if i
wasn't a comedian what i would want to
do with my life
and so um he wrote his uh hook and he
was performing and then
um i was like you know be great snoopers
if you could sing a verse uh on the song
a rap
um because i'm very cool that's what i
called it could you sing a rap verse
and uh he was like uh you know i wasn't
planning on doing a verse i was just
planning on singing the hook and i was
like oh it'd be great uh
if you could do the verse and he kind of
puts his head down
and he's like okay i'll do it and then
he looks over at one of his guys
who's standing by the door and he kind
of narrows his gaze and he goes hey
bring in the hose
at which point um a man with a garden
hose did not come into the room
but instead around five women dressed
like strippers came into the room
um and they danced he they played the
beat and they danced around for like 20
minutes as he wrote a verse on his
blackberry
um and as soon as he was done writing
the verse
he kind of with a wave of the hand like
dismissed the hose
and it flooded my head with questions
[Laughter]
like the weird thing he wasn't planning
on writing a rap
[Laughter]
so if he needs his army of hoes to
appear
whenever he writes a wrap does he have
them around just in case
like that's what i couldn't believe yeah
it's like he has an army of muse that he
busses around
in case someone's like hey can you write
a wrap he's like yeah bring in the hose
okay dance but
that must be very expensive because not
everyone's asking him to write raps all
the time
um where were they i didn't see them
before this
i didn't know i don't know where he was
keeping that hot air
hot air balloon yeah i think they travel
in a hot air balloon
he wants us down there set it down they
release the they come down
they repel in every time um and uh
overall uh i shouldn't be saying ho is
also something that uh
i better probably just to make you you
know just to
make use of them he probably does it for
emails and stuff
yeah exactly two of them come in for an
email
for a tweet for a text just maybe one
like okay
you know but i did i was actually asked
him once like why did you do that with
the hose and he's like got to make sure
it's bumping
he has an answer irrefutable do you ever
think
what's fascinating to me about about
your career and reading about your
childhood
is you there was a lot of things that
you were interested in doing and you
you had ambitions but you never dreamed
probably that you would achieve the
level that you have achieved
no and so you've been now you're kind of
a ceo
more or less and and you're in meetings
constantly and
in demand people want to talk to you big
big names
yes want you in a meeting have you ever
been in a meeting where you sort of
stepped outside your body and thought
i can't believe this person's talking to
me oh all the time
um but yeah the weirdest one um
and uh i reference this in my book uh is
uh tom cruise
um and not and and not just tom cruise
talking to me but actively uh
trying to make me a scientologist
how long ago how long ago was this um
this was in i guess 2000 uh
when we were filming knocked up so uh uh
six or so was he going through that
period
was it kind of a difficult period where
he was literally jumping on the opposite
side
on couches jumping on couches um married
to katie holmes
um viewed generally uh
as a crazy person at this time um i
don't think i'm uh
exaggerating that and so uh judd apatow
who i was working with
got a call that tom cruise wanted to
meet with us um and
that he wanted to talk about comedy
ideas and in my head i was like it's
probably so he doesn't
uh seem crazy which is a very smart uh
strategy
um and so we and am i also i was like
does he want to make a scientologist
you know and so um we went to his house
and we're talking for several hours just
about movies he has
stories about stanley kubrick it was
amazing and he wasn't bringing up
scientology
and honestly at first i was very
insulted because i thought like
am i not good enough yeah yes people
what am i trap liver
what do they want from me come on they
got kirstie alley and not me
come on
[Laughter]
what are we doing here what are we doing
you know giovanni rabisi
you know and so
i'm so glad i'm medicated right now
exactly
we're all in a storm of trouble now
people who will just beat the living
one of these people is going to beat me
up just so you it's going to happen so
i was uh maybe tom cruise so i was at
tom cruise's yeah
and then finally he starts to bring up
scientology and he's
he's saying how uh the perception of
scientology is not what
uh it should be and that people have a
real you know
a bad idea of what it is and he i'll
never he i'll never forget how he words
he looked at me and judy goes if you
just let me talk to you and tell you
what scientology
really was for like half an hour
you would say no way man
you would say no way that's what
scientology is
no way if you just gave me half
an
hour of your time
and so there's a real moment where it's
pressurized because
he's waiting for us to say yes and i
look over at judd
and i'm like i'm not going to say yes
because i genuinely don't think i'm
strong enough to not become a scientist
[Applause]
tom cruise wants me to be one yeah i'm
such a fan of this
yeah i'm very easily influenced yeah as
well
i've i've filmed entire movies i look
back on i'm like why how did that happen
so you'd have done it you would have
done it for sure would have done it
but thank god judd was like no we don't
want to talk about that
and because of that i'm probably less
successful now than i would be if i was
a scientologist you'd be so much more
successful i would be
i'd be in this new top gun movie
uh you know i have to say you have been
a real
uh you've been a gentleman to just
you've been a great guy
you came on the late night show um all
through the years you've stopped by
and when we needed uh we wanted someone
to start off a show kick off a show or
show up here towards the end
you're always there and you're always
hilarious and uh you're a mensch as i
told you about it you did it's an honor
honestly an honor to be here it's a
joy of my career that i get to do things
like this and uh that i get to
see a real audience seth rogen ladies
and gentlemen